[Música]
buenas tardes queridos amigos
y ya vamos a hacer inicialmente una
pequeña pregunta que espero me los
respondan con sinceridad
a quienes les gusta la matemática plante
en la mano
bueno a veces la respuesta es
básicamente obvia quizás desde niños no
nos ha gustado a medida que hemos ido
creciendo y obviamente los dos malos no
porque son matemáticos pero por el hecho
de
quiero mostrarles las dos matemáticas
que conozco una matemática es la
matemática formal esta matemática que la
aprendemos desde la escuela en los
colegios y algunos en la universidad la
matemática
formal está dividida en dos campos la
matemática pura y la forma
la matemática pura habla de las
geometrías y habla del álgebra abstracta
habla del análisis funcional etcétera
etcétera etcétera
la matemática aplicada en cambio habla
de la teoría de fractales la teoría del
caos la teoría de la información
etcétera etcétera etcétera
no nos interesa mucho esa matemática
como no levanta a todos los lados la
mano entonces vamos a hablar de esta
matemática de esta matemática que se
dice es la matemática no
nosotros realmente hemos tenido muchas
experiencias entre la matemática no
formal yo la catalogó a la matemática
recreativa esa matemática que nos
divierte esa matemática que nos encanta
es temática que nos hace manejar este
tipo de juegos
este juego les comento fue creado por
ernö rubik potencial inventado por ernö
rubik un profesor húngaro
en 1974 en los años 80 este juego se
hizo demasiado popular ganó el primer
premio a nivel internacional como el
mejor rompecabezas es un concurso que lo
lanzaron en alemania miren lo bueno de
esto
cuando tenemos el contacto con este
juego inicialmente nos cuesta armarlo
nos puedes mostrar todas las
posibilidades que pueden haber de
movimiento de tal forma que con lo que
se coloque en su posición original esta
matemática
aparte de divertirnos muchas veces nos
estresa cuando no podemos armarlo
yo soy sincero alguna vez
lo dejé un buen tiempo pero no tiene que
ser tomar el asunto y lo logra armar
evidentemente ahora existen muchos
algoritmos que hacen de que la
matemática
está expresada en este juego de una
manera muy compleja
evidentemente la anécdota es que el
profesor es no su vehículo fábrica pero
una vez que los desacomodan ya no han
podido acomodarlo
es una persona en un posteriori que lo
ha logrado armar de nuevo bueno en
realidad les voy a dar dos aspectos de
este juego uno bueno bien como acápite
sabemos que existen muchos muchos cubos
ahora yo tengo una colección nomas
expectable pero varios cubos con
diferentes formas con diferentes
algoritmos de solución también pero
vamos a hablar principalmente de este
les comento que por el número de
esquinas que tiene que son 8 las aristas
que son 12 se hacen operaciones de
factoriales de números y que creen que
cuantas cuantas posiciones de cuántas
permutaciones creen que yo puedo lograr
con este juego
a ver a alguien
me dice más
más de 40 millones de mucho más saben
cuánto y les presento al número
se los voy a leer ya para que parezca
atractivo es 43 trillones 252 mil 3
millones 274 mil 489 millones 856 mil
permutaciones
o sea un número de los que se llaman la
matemática titánico
como es titánico pero miren no es lo que
nosotros en realidad queremos
se ha demostrado también que saben que
hay concursos del cubo de surf que ahora
se están armando en menos de 5 segundos
se sabe que con con menos de 20
movimientos no se puede armar tiene que
ser de 20 movimientos para arriba para
llegar a 43 trillones y es mucho no
ese es un reto la matemática está allí
con esa cantidad tan grande de
movimiento y nosotros somos capaces de
hacerlo les aseguro que en menos con
menos de 200 movimientos
tenemos ese poder de selección
además para complementar alguna vez me
preguntaron pero qué más tiene este cubo
en algo que es importante
los cinco movimientos en un algoritmo
básico que logra el armado de este cubo
se corresponden con las condiciones que
debe cumplir una estructura algebraica
llamado grupo
en algunos casos y los movimientos
correctos grupos apelan a cinco
condiciones cinco movimientos por tanto
su comportamiento de este juego es una
estructura algebraica
la otra matemática que seguimos aquí que
es matemática de la vida
es aquella matemática interpersonal una
chiquitita
e
una persona va al mercado se lleva 100
bolivianos
gasta en compras otros le paga a la
señora los 100 bolivianos tienen los 83
y ahora no tiene 3 pesos y no pero sobre
los 100 como voy a dar 3 pesos más
bueno si usted me da tres yo les doy 20
pero la gente la piensa
no creo que tengo no camine no más por
favor no tengo tres aunque lo tuviera si
es ética de sustracción simple que las
señoras de muy de muy una condición tal
vez matemática muy tal vez está limitada
podríamos decirlo pero no me gusta la
palabra lo hacen lo hacen a diario
es sorprendente y a mí me sorprende
algunas veces cuando hacen las sumas y
las restas inmediatamente
quiero comentarles una
una pequeña historia acontecida y se van
a dar cuenta la magia de los números
sucede que se encuentran dos personas un
millonario
y un hombre como una persona como
cualquiera de nosotros
la persona que es una persona común le
dice al millonario señor bueno en cuenta
siempre que a veces dicen el dinero
llama al dinero no es el señor yo le voy
a dar cada día diez mil bolivianos
el millonario sí y qué debo hacer yo
usted debe darme cada día un centavo de
boliviano
no puede ser si yo le voy a dar 10 mil
bolivianos por día durante 30 días cada
día diez mil diez mil 10.000 y usted en
cambio le va a dar un centavo el primer
día al día siguiente dos centavos al día
siguiente cuatro centavos y así vamos
duplicando los centavos hasta el día
número 30 qué le parece
bueno el millonario y siempre yo nací
para hacer negocios acepta
con el problema y resulta
cuánto creen que invierte el que le da
de 10.000 en 30 días 300.000
cuando creen que el otro pago miren esta
friolera
0 1 0 0 0 1 un centavo primer día más el
segundo 1000 2 centavos con una minucia
y así se va sumando el día 30 5 millones
368 mil y pico de bolivianos y 22
pero no se quería morir hizo el trato no
podía quebrar lo él aceptó el trato pero
eso no es todo ese es el día 30 ahora
hay que sumar los aciertos
hay que sumar el día 30 el día 29 el día
28 27 hasta llegar al día 1 que era 0.01
uno de bolivia o sea un centavo
esa es la serie matemática que se
utiliza es la que está en forma de dama
la cantidad de dinero en total que pagó
el millonario por solamente recibir 300
mil bolivianos pueden 10 millones 737
mil 418 con 23 centavos
qué tal
cuando uno conoce los números puede
aprovecharse
y cuando uno no conoce puede estar en
desventaja
la idea de este problema es que todos
tenemos la capacidad de poder hacer
razonamientos simples porque esto es
aritmética básica llegado un momento es
sumar sumar solamente pero a veces
nosotros nos dejamos apantallar por el
problema y creemos que estamos ganando
cuando en realidad
podemos estar bien
se dan cuenta
veamos
la tercera parte de esta marca no formal
esto es interesante porque se acontece
normalmente en una plazuela no sé
en cochabamba sucre donde usted es de
los centros donde la gente está
avanzando bastante o caminando perdón
entonces
pero quiere apostar a las tres tapitas y
una pelotita no nos dicen
carlitos carlitos se va por la izquierda
cálix por la derecha donde está carlitos
perdiste
otra vez carlito por la izquierda o por
la derecha de carlito por allá
perdiste
esta es una matemática de supervivencia
es lo que sucede
este ha sido planteado en un problema de
aplicación de un proyecto de
investigación y una tesis de matemática
y a un nivel porcentual pero obviamente
no era el centro de atracción era uno de
los problemas en realidad lo que sucede
es lo siguiente cuando empezamos el
juego tenemos tres tapitas una pelotita
se supone que la pelotita este una
tapita y las otras dos están vacías
cuanto % tienes de perder
66% cuanto tienes de ganar 33% pero como
el otro señor hace movimiento sea rápido
entonces es la velocidad de la mano
versus la velocidad de la vista cierto
muchos lo han catalogado de esa manera
en
no están
tan que yo le voy a ganar con mi vista y
él me va a ganar con la mano si no es el
gráfico que él realiza al mover las
tapitas les comento
las 3
responden a una matriz de tres por tres
es lo que van venga y entre paréntesis
es una matriz de probabilidades esto es
un problema de denominado la cadena de
markoff
la matriz se llama matriz doblemente
estocástico eso significa que suma a sus
filas
siempre 1 y sumar las columnas siempre 1
para poder decir que el juego es honesto
muy bien cuando hace los movimientos es
lo que sucede nosotros tenemos la matriz
y tenemos el gráfico que es la persona
que está realizando el juego realiza
cuántas veces o las veces la mayor
cantidad de veces que él puede girar y
es mejor para ti porque tú puedes
visualizar decir no ha movido por aquí
porque no me interesa dónde está la
bolita primero no te interesa
matemáticamente no te interesa se mueve
gira puedes perder la primera
lateralmente dices te perdiste perfecto
en la siguiente les quiero apostar de
nuevo por el doble a esa matriz le vas a
multiplicar por sí misma el resultado te
va a dar el radio espectral pensado
espectral es el que indica en qué tapita
está en la tapita que es la clave por
más que lo gire 45 veces tú ves el
gráfico en la segunda vez y tú dices
esto se encuentra en
las tapas ganaste qué es lo que pasa con
esta magia de las matrices las matrices
picadas por sí mismo ya invierte el
problema tú ya no tienes el 66% de
perder como era un inicio tú tienes el
66 por ciento de ganar y un 33 por
ciento de perder pero como puede ser eso
acaso hay dos bolitas no te puede dar el
lujo de equivocarte
pero estas estoy seguro que puedes
elegir
una de las tapitas y siempre vas a ganar
vas a repetir el mismo juego con la
misma persona porque él tiene un patrón
de movimiento que tú ya conoces
también movimiento puedes perder una vez
le pides de nuevo nuevamente que lo haga
te vuelves a ganar y le vuelves a ganar
él no va a poder crear más patrones más
que uno o dos
este problema alguna vez se presentó con
un amigo que era de camargo muy
jovencito
y le ganaba tantas veces al apostador
que el apostador ya que no son gente de
fiar no le quería decir no le dejen
salir a este chico no es que no tiene
que toda la plata no y al final terminó
perdiendo algo y es así hay personas
de alguna manera
tienen desarrollado un sentido común a
diferencia de otros a otros nos ha
costado estudiar pero en cambio otros y
estoy seguro que algunos de ustedes lo
hace de manera natural no necesita
agarrar un libro para saber matrices
simplemente observan como les digo ese
amigo lo veía el gráfico veía
sin ganador así como lo haces de fácil y
no me no vendía ganadoras era natural de
era el estudiante de colegio no y
después los años me enseñaron que esto
tenía un fundamento matemático y hay
mucha terminología mucha mucha anotación
que a veces aburre en el fondo nosotros
podemos creer que estamos haciendo una
matemática no formal por la actividad
que la hacemos por la simpleza de la
realización pero en el fondo tiene un
fundamento matemático que sustenta esa
matemática no formal como formal pero
nadie nos dice y seguimos con la
práctica rutina de de rutina de todos
los días yo mismo cuando recorremos las
calles cuando subimos unas gradas
estamos yendo pendientes
yo les digo en síntesis
cada uno de nosotros
cada uno de nosotros es capaz
d
sentirnos matemáticos
la matemática es transversal como lo es
el lenguaje
y cada uno de nosotros acaso para hablar
bonito necesariamente tienes que saber
leer quizás así
pero en realidad es la persona que se
adecua a poderlo hacer
de una manera natural yo he visto mucha
gente en los números fundamentalmente
que no ha necesitado una ingeniería o
una ciencia matemática para poder tener
un sentido común
ahora les pregunto
cuartos ahora nos sentimos matemáticos
de acuerdo a estas experiencias que se
ven cada día cuántos levanten la mano
hay algunos que todavía no yo creo que
es la mayoría
es así
para terminar
quiero dejar una pequeña frase y qué es
lo que me ha mantenido durante mucho
tiempo desde que tienen contacto muy
serio con las matemáticas
hacer matemáticas es vivir el día a día
con intensidad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]